mathieu c'est le poison incarner je
pense qu'il doit avoir un vrai mal être
en lui pour diffuser autour de lui c'est
delphine tous les dames c'est toi qui en
a c'est pas moi ma seule pensée c'était
qu' il n'y a pas une eau dont 2 doit pas
mettre de politique dans fort boyard
point barre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien priorité au direct regardez nous
nous suivons le convoi du président de
tpm père et lui à plus de 145 consent
des mois c'est magnifique j'aperçois une
main qui s'agite une barbe bien taillée
des cheveux toujours un peu gras
malheureusement oui c'est bien lui c'est
notre résidence et badin
extraordinaire il est évidemment
accompagné de la première dame danielle
maquereau ou quoi la chaudière de
l'elysée comme la surnommait à l'elysée
justement ils sont beaux ils sont bien
entourés d'enfants alors est ce que ce
sont les leurs on ne sait pas on se bat
a longtemps été l'amant d'angela merkel
et du crash a en tout cas on attend
résonner l'hymne européen cette fois ci
non pas d'une journée du miniou des
paysans affiche clairement la couleur
place à la jeunesse quelle classe cahill
dignité
et sa femme danielle macro celle qui
évidemment aucune place extrêmement
importante dans le coeur des fans qu'ils
essaient leclerc toujours fait tout pour
se faire beau y avait argué au jeton
envers la montée encore un ordi ne
manient le producteur de thé pp voilà
c'est beau c'est grand c'est historique
je connais d'apprendre vivent ce qu'ils
soient s'adresser si vite évidemment on
entend les gens
bavard président puisque l'on trouve par
8 à baron nous y label sera car il avait
le bon niveau
record battu
randa vague évidemment si santos que
vents qui accompagnent la venue du
nouveau président de thé bnb très belle
réélection évidemment je descends 45%
des voix c'est bon sens historique on
est en 2022 ou baba est à nouveau
président de tpm p c'est magnifique
cameron ni quelle classe il s'appelle un
porno
cette instance jeudi la france la
république
la maire
tout ce qu'on aime
on était obligé de faire cette encre et
ont été obligés de faire ça a marché
mais et la marque
écoles
sont les cash machine du 21e siècle les
candidats de télé-réalité tassement de
produits booking série documentaire ceux
qui ont réussi à se démarquer à la télé
en effet un véritable business ce qu'ils
ont compris que c'était la monétisation
de l' image et que ça faisait partie de
l'armée voilà donc ce sont donc les ses
salaires temps était donc révélée est ce
que ça vous choque vous ces salaires ou
est ce que vous dites moi ça me choque
pas parce que voilà c'est normal mathieu
tout ça ne choque pas non c'est un vrai
métier j'ai juste envie de dire bravo
quoi femmes bravo 2 2 parfois aussi un
petit peu vulgaire avec c'est ce qui
peut choquer mais en même temps ils ont
20 ans j'aurais fait pareil à matin
j'aurais acheté des grosses bagnoles et
démontrer tout ça mais plutôt bravo
alors vous vous êtes choqués oui moi ça
me choque parce que ces sommes là elles
sont énormes et si elles étaient
déclarés en france parce que je le
rappelle la majorité des 10 profils
qu'on voit ici sont expatriés
fiscalement boucher avait autant
d'argent que cinar non non non mon
propos mais participent à l'effort
collectif et cyril
participer à l'effort collectif c'est à
dire que bien avant de partir et quand
ils reviendront pas ce qu'ils vont
revenir et qui vont se retrouver à
l'hôpital eh ben ils vont être bien
content que
nabila seront d'ailleurs bon et ben
voilà c'est comme les joueurs de foot
pour moi par mérite c'est évidemment que
c'est choquant pour les gens qui aiment
le ski je le conçois bien volontiers
mais ce sont les les huit premiers là
les huit premières elles ont créé des
entreprises qui en plus ont du succès
elle emploie des gens alors c'est c'est
pas vrai que hugo c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai que tout est à dubaï non j'ai
dit qu'il aurait exercées la wii mais où
la majorité qu'ils exigent les nazis y
en a plus de la moitié chez imposée
s'est imposée en france quand l'activité
est en france là où j tu te trompes tu
dis c'est comme les genres de foot c'est
pas comme un joueur de foot parce qu'un
joueur de foot moi pourquoi j'ai
toujours dit que ça me dérangeait pas
les 800 milles 1 million d'euros par
mois parce que sur les 1 million 600
mille qui restent en france parce que tu
peux pas dire et il est parti à dubaï
ont de larges ou à rennes on l'a vu
jouer à nice on a besoin
joue à l'écran
non moi je suis pas choqué par les
montants parce que s'ils font rapporter
de l'argent aux marques n'y a pas de
problème le seul souci effectivement
c'est cette histoire d'impôts parce
qu'il ya dans les influenceurs des
influenceurs français qui gagnent juste
un peu moins qui sont pas dans vos
tableaux et au final payent des impôts
beaucoup
par exemple tu fais des placements de
produits tu peux aider un peu tout est
là qu est ce que tu as une boîte à
l'étranger pour des pannes est-ce que tu
ailles l'annoncent sur ces gens là qui
ont et dont on a abusé nouveau tant que
producteur et de chaînes télé il ya
vingt ans les candidates et les rites et
ont pas fait du tout d'oseille et je
sais très bien qu'aujourd'hui le stock
se soit renversé que et que aujourd'hui
près de moi ils prennent le pouvoir et
qu'ils prennent un peu d'oseille parce
que lecture pendant des années on les a
utilisés ils n'ont pas eu de retour sur
leur investissement et aujourd'hui voilà
c'est très bien aimé en france il faut
dire que l'évangile au ghana par exemple
celui
d'hier marine le pen je vais voter pour
elle parce que c'est une gentille maman
elle a des petits chatons tout mignon
dernier alors que la production de fort
boyard a décidé de conserver son rôle
dans l'émission peu importe ses opinions
matthieu delormeau s'en est offusqué la
dame blanche s'était déjà vu elle joue
une dame et pure
il est même allé plus loin en comparant
directement delphine à l'humoriste
dieudonné condamné plusieurs fois pour
l'incitation à la haine et pour
discrimination raciale
alors mathieu est il allé trop loin avec
delphine ce soir elle lui répond en
exclusivité dans tpm je pense que ça n'a
étonné personne non mais c'est bien pour
ça que ça pas fait beaucoup de bosses en
a été donnée personnes
le dire mathieu c'est le poison incarner
je pense qu'il va y avoir un vrai mal
être en lui pour diffuser autant plus qu
enfin autour de lui
je suis pas étonné parce que mathieu
rêve d'être comédien alors que c'est
peut-être d'ici ce fait si je me fais
virer il peut prendre ma place ça se
trouve la perruque bleue ça lui va très
bien mais manque de pot je suis pas
virer donc les seuils pour l'année
prochaine enfin voila je ne sais pas
quoi de dire je trouve ça tellement au
sort tu me fais pitié en fait
il ya deux choses que tu aimes tu es pas
vraiment d'admission demain
des choses regarde même pas elle a pris
en grippe l'argent qui t'aime toi même
j'ai contacté des avocats donc je peux
porter plainte contre x pour diffamation
et injures pu me prendre l'oseille en
plus
alors ce sera fini du terrain ce n'est
pas ce que
ça l'a blessé mathieu dieudonné fins et
c'est un comparatif que tu ne peux pas
faire c'est vraiment le coeur du sujet
c'est de comparer à dieudonné en fait tu
ne fait que renforcer l'idée que les
gens qui votent extrême droite quand il
est confiant tous des fous bams à quel
moment il ya eu comparaison comme cela
que l'on meilleure comparaison elles
peuvent être aussi dieudonné dans une
émission a calé
non c'est pas les joints sont les mots
la division à mettre des gens qui ont
dépensé à mon sens extrême comme elle
n'est pas le seul à penser que si vous
répondez tout seul à la réponse extrême
je tenais je lui dis que je ne le droit
de concèze qui sera horaires donc son
père et sa mère pour le renard attend
dans les salles à la défense les moyens
mais en les faisant passer pour vendre
les mathieu il allait plus en passer
pour des monstres tu ne fait que
renforcer mais cyril je m'arrêter là
parce que tu es beau tu fais ce qu'il te
ma mère qui n'est qui n'est plus là j'ai
du poison en moi je suis une merde je le
pense aussi qu'on sait qu'il ya un petit
débat de fond j'ai décidé de
m'arrêter là j'ai eu plus de bas avec
toi ça va ça fait bizarre où est basé le
vendrai pas ma mère et je sais plus ce
que dédain ça va s'arrêter là et du
poison et je sais pas moi je m'arrêter
là delphi moi tellement méchant je
m'arrêter lettres pourquoi coup
tellement méchant à bâle avec les autres
à balamand alors sur le vois je pensais
qu'on discutera à peu du fond j'ai du
poison je suis une merde je veux être
comédien je vendrai ma mère qui est
morte donc jean mois m'arrêter là voilà
mon histoire ok effectivement tu lui
dénie le droit d'avoir une réflexion il
a le droit de penser que tu n'avais tu
ne peux pas être sur fort boyard ce
n'est pas ce que je pense mais s'il a
dit que la tendance est à
la carte c'est delphine de tous les
dames c'est toi qui en a c'est pas moi
ma seule pensée c'était qu' il n'y a pas
il nous donne ne doit pas mettre de
politique dans fort boyard point bas
touché quelqu'un qui avait de
l'affection ou qu'ils avaient un minimum
de respect ne m'aurait jamais comparer à
dieudonné vendredi soir quand j'étais
chez moi en train de pleurer devant ma
télé et en a rajouté une couche pourquoi
t'as fait ça qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour que tu fasses ça honnêtement
d'affiner je pense pas que ce soit
contre toi je pense que ça aurait pu
être quelqu'un d'autre c'est que mathieu
aussi je me permets mais mathieu a une
façon un petit peu provocante aussi de
dire les choses et de manager je me suis
dit heureusement briser un très bon
producteur mais là il est allé trop loin
non mais je te tue regrette d'avoir fait
débat c'est pas ma nature
je réponds pas
le
cadre des débats en effet à milhas avec
cyril mais je vais tout donner sur mes
amis et tous démarré et on va tout
donner mais temarii un débat avec du
poison pas quelqu'un porte que mathieu
n'a pas de poison ici il veut mon pays
de mon métier il vendrait sa mère et a
commencé avec man fin d'histoire et
franchement je sais que j'ai pas bon
très souvent quitté le plateau je le
quitte pas par politesse mais je me tais
terminé donc ne me pose pas de questions
tu parles de poison de machin d'évoquer
une image à l'époque litois autre image
ap tandis que quand tu me lance comme ça
eh bien eh ben ça reste pas sur le net
et a besoin de moi pour te faire une
image on est sur le débat d'idées car
ici on est sur la confrontation et là on
y trouvait lui la juste rajouter une
pelletée dessus mais pensez aux idées en
seo ces idées moi je vous ai défendu le
droit d'exprimer vos aînés jugé que ça
aide va tu as le droit aussi de
s'exprimer là là vous êtes en train
d'établir une chanson infernale et
arrêter de penser que c'est contre vous
delphine c'est contre vous avez dit
hier soir le couple qui a fait le plus
parler c'est iman et melvin qui se parle
sur les réseaux sociaux depuis cinq ans
du problème iman est tombée amoureuse
d'un fétichiste qui drague beaucoup de
filles on va revenir à la tête ça parle
des chariots j'entends déjà humaine ça
va ça va et toi oui tu es magnifique
vraiment réagir j'aime beaucoup les
pieds oui je sais que tu es fétichiste
non je suis pas parti qu'ils imaginent
ont par la suite tu vas devenir ma femme
ou je sais pas fauquet les pompiers
et je peux les voir si possible on verra
ça plus tard
imed vous est éducatrice sportive à
marseille vous avez vous avez divorce à
19 ans est parachutiste dans l'armée et
vous avez fait voilà vous étiez
exactement et humaine 1 vous discutiez
avec melvin c'est ça elle a été déçue
déçue hier soir ou melvin a oublié de
raccrocher son téléphone est en fait
elle a entendu ce qu'elle n'aurait pas
dû entendre j'attends d'une discussion
tu dis à ton ami ton ami tu disais alors
la fille que tu ne vois pas
ça dit oui c'est frank thomas ce même si
j'ai fantômas y en a d'autres j'en ai
beaucoup d'autres
c'était fantômas parce qu'on se voyait
pas ligue en gros tu discutes avec une
autre femme
je préfère le garder en ami je pense que
ça sert à rien qu'en plus
je pense qu'on est sur l'as cannes zone
ce qui m'a énervé donc c'est qu'ils
parlent avec d'autres filles tu n'as pas
tu l'as pas accepter ça et pourquoi
mais pas ça va il peut parler
amicalement avec youtube quoi j'en avais
parlé est ce que tu pars avec d'autres
femmes sur tous les
tableaux très spécial a vraiment été un
peu trop mis des sites avait été avec
elle voilà vite avec un peu trop carré
c'est ça c'est ça tu es parce que c'est
l'ancien militaire franchement c'est des
coquetteries te dis g27 il a 24 et il
parle avec deux filles pas
jamais vu après une demande en mariage
non mais c'est vrai mais bien mais
qu'est ce qu'il a dit dans ces
discussions
dans cette discussion ne vous aidera
crochet son portable son ami lui poser
la question alors ça en est où avec ta
copine iman il m'a dit oui dans son
collègue lesdits fonds thomass pardonne
parce qu à lui tout seul a répondu non
mais ça que moi je connais la
page tout ce monde là vraiment je
connaissais pas fantômas ouais j'arrive
par bourguiba il a une forme que je
n'existais pas mais que j'étais là c'est
mignon il répond ne t'inquiète pas je
l'aïe a pas que l1 je suis pas je suis
pas un gamin je vais pas parler juste
avec qui mène alors qu'anna plein
d'autres qui me court après mais voilà
il voit là il était un petit peu trop de
mecs mais vous avez
tout et on couple ça marche en cause
dans une fiche de fréquences on va y
aller même la série
avec elle que tu discuté pendant qu'on
se parle et au sort dépend pas du tout
pas du tout parce qu'en fait non pas du
tout c'est pas commenté la nouvelle
mariée à nice à anissa à la nicotine
ça va aller il faut signer là une maman
ours et les célibataires
d'accord c'est le mar premier regard
elle est célibataire à quoi cécile dumas
au premier regard
et ses comptes
kadhafi mais je ne crois pas elle est
dans les parages est emballé la voilà
voilà voilà ces messieurs
[Applaudissements]
la ligue 1
alors donc un esata effet mario premier
regard
on va chercher on va chercher sur google
et donc toi maintenant tu es avec avec
medicine depuis combien de temps ça fait
deux mois maintenant et alors c'est
comment s'asseoir centre bell ça se
passerait bien c'est pas du tout un chat
roux c'est pas un petit garçon
franchement
pas dans la vie de tous les jours mais
ma compagne bateau partout et h20 quatre
ans sans que les chauffeurs rumeurs
n'ont pas pris un par amour on fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment vous êtes rencontrés est même
envoyé un message sur instagram
envoyé de message en fait le premier
j'avais vu et 2n ng répondu parce qu'il
m'a fait de la peine
c'est des cons temps
ça va durer cette affaire
allez vous voulez vous faire un petit
bisou
c'est ramadan
[Musique]
vous connaissez l'arnacoeur de tender
figurez-vous que sa version française
existerait elle s'appellerait yasmine b
to b qui délie sans jamais trouver cette
escort girl de 23 ans se ferait passer
pour une riche héritière afin de mieux
dépouiller ses cibles c'est sacha
ex-candidat de the voice et ex petit ami
de la jeune fille est alertée de cette
supercherie sur son compte instagram à
la volée la quasi totalité des bijoux de
valeur de ma mère les vêtements de
marque de mon père décédé et bien
d'autres objets de valeur et apparemment
ça ne serait pas la seule victime en
publiant son message il se rend compte
que d'autres personnes auraient été
manipulés par cette certaine yasmine b
vous avez quel âge alors moi j'ai 23 ans
23 ans quand je me présente comme une ex
cette année de l'asmb est d'accord
également comme entre guillemets ne
porte pas de nombreuses victimes
d'accord je me racontait comment je les
rencontre et comment ça s'est passé
alors vous la rencontrez commandé alors
moi j'ai rencontré yasmine déjà à
l'anniversaire de mon ami par le biais
d'une copine qui voulait ramener une
copine d'accord et on a tout de suite
flirter ensemble on a été gentils très
joli très intelligent de cons est gentil
ça fleure bon mais c'est très joli sinon
dans ce cas là beaucoup à faire on va
dire que le lieu un match tout de suite
thomas fleurs temps semble rester
ensemble et les yeux les jours comment
j'ai tout découvert mais je l'ait quitté
au bout d'un mois et demi parce qu'en
fait elle essaie de me retourner contre
mon groupe d'amis parce qu'on est un
groupe on a une dizaine et elle essaie
également de retourner ce groupe d'amis
contre moi je commence à aller voir mon
ami a discuté avec elle effectivement en
fait cette fille là donc yasmine aurait
tenté deux
prostituées faire prostituées 7,7 a mis
en lisant voilà mardi on va rencontrer
des des riches millionnaires etc moi
j'ai eu écho de ça je me suis dit mais
ça c'est un truc de ouf quand je gémis
l'histoire sur les réseaux sociaux en
fait j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup de
messages honnêtement je consigne
centaines de témoignages beaucoup de
gens qui avaient porté plainte depuis
quatre cinq ans un truc comme ça et là
je me suis dit ok c'est pas du tout un
cas isolé moi je pensais c'était juste
quelqu'un qui s'était tu me varin à pied
quoi ce qui s'est passé avec ses achats
c'est que on s'est engueulé donc on a eu
beaucoup danglade vu que c'était un
amour très rapide et très passionnel
beaucoup danglade moi je comprenais pas
certaines de ses actions parce que bon
lines il mène un train de vie qui ne me
plaît pas et donc ce moment là je quitte
chez lui donc en fait vous vous appuyez
vous mener un train de vie qui lui plaît
pas et vous vous dites qu'il mène un
train de vie qui lui plaît pas oui en
fait tous les deux vous menez en train
je sais pas de quoi ils parlent en tout
cas moi son train de vie c'est son train
de vie de quoi en train de vue de
drogués voilà simplement on est parlée
en fait dans la vidéo de bastos et ça ne
me plaisait pas il me demande de venir
chercher des sacs eu lui-même a fait une
fois que je vois dans les sacs donc le
soir où sa mère me contacter je vois des
affaires qui ne sont pas à moi à ce
moment là j'ai tout jean corps en les
échangeant jeudi à sa mère je vous
rapporte tout où je vais de moi même au
commissaire si vous préférez je suis
allée au commissariat déposer toutes les
affaires sans même avoir de convocation
c'est aussi pour ça que sasha s'est
énervé parce que la police m'a dit ben
on va peut-être pas écrire au procureur
vu que vous avez été de bonne foi dès le
départ en fait ça c'est vrai quand
j'étais plus jeune donc moi je viens
d'une famille très modeste mon éducation
n'a pas été très limité c'est à dire que
en j'avais les mauvaises fréquentations
j'étais vu dans ma petite ville comme
une petite délinquante on aller par
exemple à intermarché ont volé débouté
des fois on a poussé à un personnel de
la sécurité etc donc oui oui j'ai volé
des personnes à cette période là c'est
pour ça qu'ils parlent de deux
procès-verbaux et d'attac contre moi
d'il ya quatre cinq pourquoi il ya
autant de témoignages contre vous si
vous êtes complètement innocente parce
qu'en fait c'est surtout les gens de
cognac y ont réagi et il y a cinq
personnes que j'ai effectivement volé
donc j'ai pris en photo leurs cartes
bancaires et j'ai effectué des
transactions avec mais j'assiste sur ça
les crises étaient à hauteur de 200
euros et on avait cinq maximum train
quand j'ai entendu ça et j'en suis
désolé envers ces victimes là bien sûr
mais bon j'ai eu mon passé mon passé de
délinquant tout ce que j'ai fait des
erreurs quand j'étais plus jeune mais à
l'heure actuelle sincèrement je me suis
fait tellement d'argent avec l'escorting
que jeune homme il a escorté monde et
les scorpions sont les méthodes est ce
que vous cherchiez quelle personne
envoie sa merde et des photos que c'est
vrai les maux sociaux chantage et tout
ça c'était pas c'était pas
de chantage c'est juste c'est dit et
regardez votre drogué deux fils j'ai
pété un câble parce qu'on est juste de
se quitter parce qu'il m'a insulté comme
pas possible c'était de l'amour quand on
ressent de l'amour et qui il m'insultait
comme ça qu'il me traite de [ __ ] devant
tout le monde qu'il
j'étais énervé je n'ai photo à sa maman
vous allez voir sa meilleure amie pour
lui dire si c'est vrai cette histoire de
vous avez été voir sa meilleure amie
pour voir si elle pouvait faire des
scores aussi davantage is you j'ai juste
proposé à cette fille là je lui ai dit
je vais un match de basket c'est un mec
qui m'a contacté il est super riches il
m'a donné de plage tu peux venir avec
moi c'est encore quand même oui mais non
c'est est l escorting ne l'est pas je
les rencontre en floride un match de
basket avec un gars vit avec moi il est
hyper riches ne connaît pas on est
encore un petit je me suis tu va
ressentir avec des soldes 2009 en fait
je vais talent est toujours escort
annonce à arrêter ces raisons là à la
fin je travaillais en fait je
travaillais pour la brp voilà et
j'allais dans certaines soirées j'ai
aussi l'épreuve et je prouverai parole à
verser la brigade de répression contre
le proxénétisme mais qu'elle était
indique ou pas je te le disais et je te
les ai envoyé les messages elle m'avait
dit qu'elle était un deal montrer j'en
ai parlé avec son pote qui m'a dit non
je fais juste draguer par des policiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]